mais d'abord cette question comment
enrayer la désertification médicale dans
notre région nous l'avons tous constaté
les délais pour avoir accès à un rendez
vous médical sont plus en plus long
faute de professionnels la région centre
cherche donc des médecins désespérément
pour remédier à ce problème
elle ambitionne de créer d'ici 2025 150
postes de médecins salariés dans les
territoires sous dotées exemple à bosse
la romaine une nouvelle médecin vient
d'arriver dans ce petit village de 3500
âmes dans le nord-est du loiret cher
laurent clavel
cet après midi c'est monsieur le maire
qui fait la visite du futur cabinet
médical
après avoir tenté de faire venir des
médecins français puis roumains et
espagnol il a enfin trouvé la perle rare
à une centaine de kilomètres de la
commune
une jeune médecin tourangelle jusqu'à
présent les habitants devaient parcourir
18 kilomètres pour se faire soigner
est ce qui me satisfait déjà c'est une
jeune médecin donc ça c'est quelque
chose de très positif
est-ce que ça doit oublier ton père n
est un jeune médecin qui a tout pour ali
mitha montrer ce qu'il veut faire
mais je pense que pour lui c'est une
aventure mais c'est une très très belle
aventure pour attirer ce médecin la
communauté de communes a profité du
dispositif de médecins salariés un cdd
de trois ans signé avec la région qui
prend en charge le salaire
le médecin lui il trouve son bonheur pas
de loyer à payer des horaires fixes et
pas de paperasse
je me serais pas installés dans cette
région là s'ils savaient pas été avec le
soutien de structures telles que celle
ci parce que il faut on a peur sinon de
s'isoler beaucoup quand on va dans
dans des endroits comme ça que l'armée
tente dans cette structure là ça permet
quand même mais à terme j'espère
rapidement de recruter des collègues
comme elle quatre médecins ont déjà
franchi le pas du salariat en centre val
de loire
ils seront bientôt 8 avec un objectif
150 d'ici 2025
un outil qui doit permettre de lutter
contre les déserts médicaux sacs des six
départements de la région ici en vert
foncé ou perdu jusqu'à 11 % de leurs
effectifs en dix ans pour dire les
choses franchement
une très grande partie du territoire
régional une partie de l'indre et loire
en effet est aujourd'hui assis bien
pourvues je dis bien une partie parce
qu'on à la fac de médecine en indre et
loire
mais y compris sur certains quartiers de
tours qui sont des quartiers peu
favorisés on a un manque de médecins
c'est dire combien il nous faut avancer
et avancer vite à bosse la romaine la
nouvelle médecin accueillera son premier
patient début mai pour la commune
l'espoir que son expérience donne des
idées à d'autres confrères car les
besoins sont énormes
ici la patiente elle est estimée à dix
mille personnes